everyone knows that there's a freedom
convoy in canada there's people
protesting vaccine and mass mandates but
yesterday the canadian government
ratcheted up their attack on these
hard-working citizens what am i talking
about here's a video of the canadian
government literally saying that they
now are going to use anti-money
laundering and terrorist financing
regulation and legislation to go after
these individuals they are quite
literally going to label hard-working
citizens as terrorists don't believe me
hear it directly from them we are
announcing the following immediate
actions
first we are broadening the scope of
canada's anti-money lauder laundering
and terrorist financing rules
so that they cover crowd funding
platforms
and the payment service providers they
use
these changes cover all forms of
transactions
including digital assets
such as
currencies now this is absolutely insane
we have the canadian government quite
literally saying that they are going to
take their citizens and if you are
participating in a protest for freedom
you are going to be labeled a terrorist
that's not exactly what a democratic
free society would do now the el
salvador president buchelli he had a
great point he basically was saying if
this wasn't canada the people
internationally would be up in arms are
these the people who like to give
lessons to other countries about
democracy and freedom this is one of the
top ranking countries in the democracy
index your credibility on these topics
is now worth zero he's got a great point
if this was happening in a third world
country or in the developing world the
international community would be up in
arms they'd be yelling about
dictatorships and authoritarian
governments but because it's canada
somehow no one's talking about it well
there's plenty of canadians and other
people on the internet who have lots of
comments here we've got josh d who said
christina freeland second in command to
pm trudeau said in a press conference
that they can now freeze canadians bank
accounts if the government suspects you
have donated 25 or more to the trucking
convoy democracy has died today in
canada he then went on to say she also
said if your vehicle is part of a convoy
the government can freeze your bank
accounts and cancel your insurance she
also says banks can do this without
court orders this is an egregious
escalation now the part of this that is
absolutely insane is that we are talking
about the ideas of democracy and due
process completely dying it doesn't
matter if you're actually doing what
they suspect you of doing you are just
deemed guilty from day one on top of
that they're actually able to go after
you and your way of living and your
property they can literally freeze your
bank accounts they can go ahead and
cancel your insurance this is peak clown
world now of course people are making
lots and lots of comparisons to china
and actual authoritarian governments
warren tagome said i'm not aligned with
the truckers but shutting down bank
accounts of protesters strikes me as too
much like the [ __ ] the ccp does to
[ __ ] critics in hong kong you lost
the plot if you call yourself a liberal
democracy while calling people you
disagree with terrorists now as i always
say the true test of free speech is to
protect what somebody is saying that you
disagree with the canadian government
not only is not doing that they're
actually taking it a step further and
they're literally saying these people
are terrorists this is insane now
preston bayern who's a lawyer here in
the united states so that canadian
police have the power to end the convoy
protest just arrest the people for
traffic violations you don't need to
invoke emergency powers the thing that's
so crazy is that it's literally a
traffic matter you can arrest people you
can put points on their license that's
it but of course when the canadian
government goes nuclear it seems like
the neolibs using canada as a policy
laboratory of these convoy protests they
spring up around the world soon
scheduled for america but hebrew had a
great point all trudeau had to do was
just be like look we respect your right
to protest but if you block the road
you're gonna be arrested never be like
damn canada so polite but now the world
is freaking out so if you block the road
he believes that you should be arrested
charged with misdemeanor disorderly
conduct or loitering or something like
that should not have your property
seized or lose your ability to earn a
living now of course there's going to be
plenty of people who disagree with the
steps that the protesters are taking
that's okay protests are supposed to
make people uncomfortable but the second
that the government doesn't act rational
the second the government begins to puff
up their chest label you a terrorist and
come after you i actually think what
they're doing is they're simply bringing
more attention to it now it's not just
canadians who believe that the canadian
government is overreaching now it's
people around the world it's me other
americans and the international
community everyone's got their eyes on
canada right now if you're gonna label
those you disagree with as terrorists
maybe you shouldn't have that much power
the ability to censor and freeze
transactions bank accounts take people's
property it's all headed in the wrong
direction ultimately what we are
watching is that the internet is
bringing the ideals of individual
liberty and personal freedoms back to
the forefront of conversation canada
stop being ridiculous treat your
citizens as fellow citizens they're not
terrorists they're simply protesting
what you're doing maybe it might help to
listen